and the way we're going to organize the
panel is that we going to have a series
from from the people who will form the
panel at the end of the session and then
another series of sessions in more
detail from from presenters who have
arrived from many parts of the world's
part of the UN GC the UN United Nations
Global colloquium fo of university
presidents so in this two-hour session I
don't think we can hope to provide a
global view of cultural heritage
education but I hope that this panel
will give a broad introduction to
current and significant programs and
universities for conservation and
demonstrate how other academic
disciplines are needed to support
preservation efforts and how academic
disciplines are tailored to Pacific
needs in conservation we will learn
about training and education for areas
where there are few resources and how
funding which is never sufficient has to
be carefully prioritized in a broader
context we will also see how University
collections can be used in a wide number
of ways to an informal enthuse
generations of students who even if they
have little to do with the preservation
of cultural heritage in their future
careers will remain alive to the
fundamental importance of its
preservation so I hope from these
discussions and questions from the
audience some ideas for possible new
initiatives and directions might arise
the way the slides are organized we've
made one Humungousaur 8 PowerPoint with
three later insertions and so as each
speaker comes up there will be a blue
slide announcing their name and their
their their the position and where
they're from and that will just give
enough time for the next speaker to get
up to the podium I did this hoping it
would save a little bit of time though
what they're just three presentations
that have to be separate inserted
separately so finally before we start
I'm going to be very strict with time
and I'm still thinking of a way of
pulling presenters off the podium if
they runs severely over so I were just
going to start this afternoon there's
the blue slide let you read it and to
talk a little about the initiatives at
Yale and I came in 2008 from you de from
the Cambridge University where I had a
very close to the existence looking back
on it running what was known as a
Hamilton car Institute which was a
an institute for training painting
conservators and we were in the
luxurious position at the time of only
taking two students every other year so
it was we did a great deal to work
otherwise but when i came to Yale I
realized that it clearly although there
was some ambitions to actually establish
a conservation program at Yale I thought
it was much more important to try and
really address a kind of further
training to conservatives who already in
the profession and so we've concentrated
on the establishment of internships at
different levels and also fellowships
and I must say that this was already
quite an active program before I arrived
both at the art gallery in the British
art center and also the library where
there has been a serious of fellowships
offered from time to time and so really
just to just to go back to my first
slide this is just our old premises
before we move to the new lab which many
of you will probably see tomorrow and
the open day on Friday we're in that
photograph we have fellows interns and
conservatives all working together in
the lab and I think this is one of the
very important parts of this aspect of
practical training that everybody works
together so really starting with pre
until we offer a pre program internship
and I'm hoping that eventually that at
Yale we can actually form this into into
a recognized program at the moment we
have a slightly odd way of doing it in
which the pre program interns or hired
as casual employees for 20 hours a week
for six months and I I think it'd be
much better that we can develop this so
we're already talking about doing this
and this is for students who have
discovered that they're interested in
pursuing a career in conservation but
are aware that in order to be accepted
or to apply to a graduate program in the
states they have to undertake a certain
amount of practical work and gain a
certain number of hours of experience
and so I think this is a useful place
where Yale has this very large
collection with them and not least in
the art gallery where there are a wide
range of projects can be done and here
purina so whose interest in becoming a
paper conservator is working with soy
and soy from the British art center the
senior conservator of paintings working
a large print and another intern who has
gone on to a conservation from this is
breanna Turner who's also working with
Carol snow and Elena toric from the art
gallery being subjected to a large
number of objects very in a very short
time as the galleries currently move him
involved in the large move of objects
from temporary storage into its new
permanent storage on west campus again
which will be be able to be seen during
tomorrow during the open day and the
tours and then we also offer internships
for students already embarked on a
course in graduate conservation course
and this is Annika finna from who's
currently in her third year fourth year
no third year sorry at New York
University the fire institute fine arts
she's a painting conservator and here
she's working with our senior
conservator paintings yep a Surrey and
her supervisor michelle moran cola is in
fact looking through the microscope as
were checking up on her progress and so
as part of this internship we report on
the students progress and and give the
directors of studies at the various
programs reports on how they're doing
and the range of work they've been
exposed to and then we also offer
fellowships ourselves and the gallery
recently has been able to raise funds so
that we had to fully funded fellowships
one and paintings conservation and one
and objects and from time to time we can
also through gifts for specific projects
we can raise money to hire a fellow and
so at the moment we're just about to
advertise for a post involving a cassone
panel we have a complete cassone and a
Cassone panel here in the gallery which
are going to be examined and treated and
so we've turned that into a two year
research and practical experience
project and here we have Ashley yaeli
who's the consider the fellow in objects
conservation working on a man ray light
shade and then on the other side anika
anika krez whose paintings annick res
who's the paintings conservative fellow
and she is working on a couple of
paintings which were examining at the
moment as part of a
ject on a particular artist Ralph Albert
Blakelock and honors from the Technical
University of Munich and Ashley trained
as a hooked a postgraduate program at
Buffalo New York State University and
came to us via Emory University which
also offers graduate fellowships and
we're able to do this in in the lab this
is our conservation laboratory see
tomorrow where we are able to by working
together in a single room all the
disciplines we can offer a wide range of
experience and we encourage students to
take an interest and if what each other
is doing and I think having this large
shared space really works and but as
well as that the as staff the art
gallery also encouraged to teach courses
and in fact we now teach a technical
examination of art course the
conservation department as an
undergraduate program for the history of
art department and here are a group of
the students at one of the classes being
introduced to portable x-ray
fluorescence on a painting and you can
just see my colleague Cindy Schwartz's
head working the machine the the
instrument and and again one of the
advantages of the gallery is that we can
encourage the students to once you've
learnt a little bit about technical
aspects and the materiality of objects
we can give them a sign of a painting or
an object each which they can study for
the final paper and so in this thing
here we're having a lecture on modern
modern technique materials and modern
paintings and on the left you can see
arranged against the wall the paintings
that they've been given to work on and
to study as part of their of their final
paper and here's one of the classes in
progress where we have some models and
reconstructions made by previous fellows
this as an early Italian painting by
powder to Stefano which is reproduced to
show how the painting was put together
and so we can use these as teaching aids
and and in addition to that we also have
started a class which where I work with
a professor of molecular biophysics
where we've set up a non-science arts
major class where in conjunction with my
colleagues in D Schwartz we teach nonlin
science art majors the rigors of a
scientific methodology and conducting
aspects Perriman
with the possible side benefit of coming
across a technique a very simple
technique for identifying materials
using peptides attached a phage which
can be in theory given the color marker
so you could actually drop a small
amount of this material onto an object
and if it if it changes color would
identify the object it's one of these
tantalizing courses where we get close
to the possibility of getting this to
work we have done a proof of concept but
but usually we find that in fact the
class ends before any concrete results
and this is some of the work in progress
by the students and one of the students
interestingly was very interested in
being able to identify genuine
tortoiseshell from from the from fake
tortoiseshell obviously it's an illicit
substance that can't be imported and CSU
was able to go to the Peabody Museum and
speak to David brucellosis here who is
actually a forensic herpetologist and he
was able to produce a stuffed version of
a hop bill sea turtle to show the entity
to be seen to see the characteristics of
genuine tortoiseshell so it's really an
indication of the kind of range of
access to materials and experts that you
have at Yale and then also we have had a
class from the school of art where they
come they've been doing a class this
year on the forms of attention where the
very interest in the way that people
look at paintings and look at objects
and the time they take and how they
regard time as regards to the work they
do so they were fascinated by looking at
this painting which is going to be a
very very long conservation process
where we're working at a scale of
millimeters and centimeters a day and to
them and to the school of our the
graduate artists they seemed almost on
a-- Shing lee small rate of progress but
to us we feel we're making quite good
progress and find it there's also
students take up projects as research
projects this is sarah novell who did a
project on the roman shields from jury
ropas and that is now part of a display
at the human whitney humanity centers
that she organized with help and then we
also offer bursaries to students who
come and work for a number of hours a
week and this is a student who's
arranged
catalogued photographed and labeled a
collection of pigments we've been given
and here's Lauren taco who's in the
process of putting them into display
cases and we've also hosted mid-career
conservators these are 23 conservators
antsy OD on the left he and a colleague
came from Haiti to work with us on two
occasions really looking at some of the
techniques that we used and we were able
to offer Haiti Haitian 19th century
paintings which are in the Peabody
collection which they worked on so that
was the sort of added bonus for from
there adding to their experience and
finally I just want to mention something
about where we're actually teaching the
teachers and with the generous support
of the crest foundation and working in
collaboration with the New York
University of Institute of Fine Arts
we've been able to run since 2011 a
program of a week-long program
introducing art history professor to the
materiality of objects and here we are
last year talking about the Roman
shields this is aaron my psycho
scientist with our conservative
colleagues to the left talking about the
scientific research and how you
interpret this and what it means in
helping to understand what we're looking
at in these shields and also we do
practical classes here as tears of
fairbanks harrison paper conservator the
british art center who got the
participants to paint watercolors in the
style of turner with water color
pigments that we knew would be fairly
fugitive and then during the rest of the
week they did this on the first day they
were subjected to accelerated aging in
the IPC h conservation labs by Paul
Whitmore and when they were brought back
at the end of the week this is the
extent of fading of one watercolor and I
think this brought home in a very very
concrete way the risks to objects from
exam extreme condition such as excessive
light or humidity so thank you very much
and that's I'm a good hand over to
debbie has Norris
you